she so quickly and easily riff on the  most ridiculous subjects it's like you  dropped you here brush in your vagina  caught it  I could make dreadlocks with that Bush  and for my reggae band it looks like a  whole ball of petrified curly fries  interesting a lot of your products but  first I need you to put all of them on  my face in a very nice way for free when  you have rebel Wilson on set every  single take is different and you know we  took so much funny stuff with her we  could like edit the sequel just of the  material we got hi I have two bags I  need to return mama's not as young as  she was last night I want full geisha  this morning and I wanted to look like a  panda took a shot and just wiped it over  my life took a [ __ ] let's go let's say  okay whoa you know a lot of people think  I'm very wild in real life because I  play a lot of wild characters but the  truth is I haven't even really been to  many nightclubs at all